dans ces quartiers clés du z plus de
deux cent soixante combattants ukrainien
il était retranché depuis des semaines
dans l' usine d'azov ce talent à
marioupol c'est un convoi certains
combattants emprunté un couloir
humanitaire en direction de la
périphérie de donetsk également contrôlé
par les forces russes et pro russe 53
d'entre eux grièvement blessés sont
transportés à une cinquantaine de
kilomètres pour assistance médicale dans
la nuit de lundi à mardi le président
zelensky a annoncé la fin des combats
je veux le souligner l'ukraine a besoin
de ces héros ukrainien vivant c'est
notre principe je pense que c'est mou
peuvent être entendus par les personnes
concernées nous continuons de faire le
nécessaire pour ramener nos gars à la
maison c'est délicat et ça demande du
temps selon kiev avant l'évacuation
près de 1000 soldats se trouvaient
encore dans les galeries souterraines de
cette aciérie devenue le symbole de la
résistance des forces d'ukrainiens à
marioupol the doc brown somme grâce au
défenseur de marioupol nous avons gagné
un temps crucial pour former des
réserves regrouper des forces et
recevoir l'aide de nos partenaires vite
partenaires
les défenseurs de marioupol ont
pleinement accompli toutes les missions
assignées par les commandes provenant
mon obsession les autorités ukrainiennes
annonce que les soldats évacués
devraient prochainement être rapatriés
en zone contrôlée par leur armée dans le
cadre d'une procédure des changes le
sort des autres combattants restés dans
l'usiné est un certain mario paul est
aujourd'hui presque entièrement détruite
ce port stratégique du sud est de
l'ukraine
est une cible de l'armée russe depuis le
début du conflit